former Senator Al Franken we're talking
in the morning as well as returning to
his roots in late night television
Frankenstein are started rather as an
original writer for Saturday Night Live
where he worked for 15 Seasons starting
tonight he will be working once again in
late night uh guest hosting the Daily
Show after Trevor Noah stepped down The
Daily Show airs on Comedy Central which
of course is a division of Paramount Al
Franken good morning good morning I
should say we were laughing because
you're already starting with a joke we
were talking about children and the
senator said that he has four
grandchildren I said what's your grandpa
name and you said call me what they call
you and what is that Senator
Senator it is I don't think he's joking
um the former president president Trump
is calling for Nationwide protests uh uh
in response his potential
his potential uh indictment
um will you be attending the protest
you're gonna be able to work that into
your job here as The Daily Show host
well I'm a proud boy us to stand back
and stand by yes so yeah I we don't know
if he's going to be indicted do we and
but uh and neither does he he did what
he did and I think it was to uh you know
get protests if if it happens does uh
the abundance of news this week make
your job harder in this late night
return or easier easier got great
material I'll bet yeah yeah no it's uh
uh but it'll be interesting if he just
doesn't get indicted so that'll but
he'll be better you know it'll be more
news if he's indicted of course well I
predict Senator you're going to kill it
you know because you're smart enough
you're good enough and doggone it people
like you oh well thanks for remembering
just something that I came up off the
top of my head I'm wondering how you're
feeling about this because number one it
seems like it's the perfect platform and
perf right up your alley to sit in this
seat and do what you're going to do are
you nervous are you excited how are you
preparing and getting ready well because
it's the perfect thing for me I'm really
nervous well yeah of course of course I
haven't really done this in this format
in a while and I've seen they've had uh
I think eight or nine other hosts yeah
uh since Trevor uh stepped back and uh
uh they've been terrific and each tries
to make it his own or her own and uh
okay so how are you going to try to make
it your own like who is well for example
tonight I have Lindsay
you know people uh you know when I when
I go around the country and people would
ask me we're friends and people would
ask me uh I did my tour like who's the
funniest
who's funding a center I'd say Lindsay
and my crowd would get really mad
he's really funny the first time uh well
when he was running for president in in
uh 2000 what what year was that uh in
he's running 16. 16 and he was doing
very badly against Trump I was in the
bathroom uh sent a bathroom with him and
I said Lindsay
if I were a republican I'd vote for you
and he said without hesitation he said
that's my problem
he's if we were friends we disagree on
almost everything but we'll talk about a
few things we agree one thing we agree
on and then of course we'll be talking
about his friend well uh the former
president so let me let's talk about
some current events uh Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis he's a strong Contender for
2024 run um he's recently LED an attack
on the word woke and whatever that means
it's come to mean something very
different by Republicans what would you
like give me some something to work with
here
well what he's done is ridiculous in
Florida he has this law that that uh if
a teacher makes a kid feel uncomfortable
about anything I guess including the
race that the the the the parent can sue
them so I mean how do you teach
how do you teach history you know
American history in Florida is like um
um for our first 200 years there were
people who um had to work for free yeah
you know uh no not
not like your father's uh
you know like the free internship you
did for your father you know I mean it's
like I've seen proposals where people
say when you're talking about Rosa Parks
you don't mention her race you just
mentioned that she was asked to step to
the back of the bus
but she chose not to do that and she
should be applauded for that you take
out the mention that she was told to sit
at the back of the bus right because
that'll make them feel uncomfortable
context matters it's a very tricky
business down in Florida right now uh
speaking of a tricky business uh so
politics you're hanging out with a
senator tonight Lindsey Graham uh and
you used to be a senator and everyone
knows the story you step down after
these allegations of sexual misconduct
which you've denied uh what might you do
to start hanging out with the 99 other
Senators uh other than Lindsey Graham uh
will you run again are you interested in
running again I've been I get asked that
all the time I
I I I have no plans to do that no no no
people have asked me to yeah run for
president but I said if the problem with
that is if I want I'd have to be
president
and uh I don't think I want but do you
miss the day-to-day Senator I do I do I
miss the day today also miss being able
to do good things for people that's
mainly what I I'm really bummed that you
looked like you really meant it you're
not interested in the future in politics
and I had a feeling you were going to
say yes it was on the sheet I thought it
was there for a reason but we got to put
it on the show a lot of people would
like to put it on the shape on The Daily
Show guest hosting tonight it is on
Comedy Central this is CBS mornings
a lot of people would like to see